you know I have to ask about your most
famous friend a very select I'm gonna
tailor a couple times like in a meet
great situation because I was a fan yet
still AM um but then she tweeted about
my EP II wouldn't let me like a minute
first came out like before anyone really
I burned her a CD and I wrote her a
letter about how much I've you know just
been inspired by her and then she
reached out and we've kind of had a
friendship ever since you know you've
arrived when Taylor Swift instagrams a
girls night in with you but Kelsea
Ballerini just won her first Academy of
Country Music Award for new female
vocalist and she's up against country
royalty Carrie Underwood and Miranda
Lambert for another ACM this Sunday
making this newcomer a force to be
reckoned with just to be a female in
country music is like so exciting but to
be like in the in those five that's it's
an honor it really is it's a great room
to be in great honey Peter Pan is the
third single off the 22-year old
Tennessee natives debut album the record
charted at number four on the top
country albums list I've never driven a
bishop until I heard that you just
learned that yeah he's like I would
never do it in real life but in video
iein lips onion kids Kelsey's got the
makings of a massive social media
following with over three hundred
thousand followers on Instagram below
that fan attention is something she's
getting used to what is the craziest fan
experience you've had in real life so I
just took a little vacation to West Palm
Beach I posted a picture just like of
the beach like where I was just like
water and a beach and an hour later
these two teenage guys come up and
they're like yes we thought this was the
same island we just came to find you now
I just post things after I leave places